[Musique]
avec voilà une phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse la visite on en parlait à
l'instant dans le journal avec damien
coquet est la visite donc à partir
d'aujourd'hui du ministre de l'intérieur
en corse français bien sûr après deux
semaines de tensions autour de
l'agression en prison de
l'indépendantiste yvan colonna avant ce
déplacement gérald darmanin a accordé un
entretien à corse matin une interview il
est sûr que le gouvernement est prêt à
aller jusqu'à l'autonomie de l'île la
question est de savoir ce qu'est cette
aune cette autonomie il faut qu'on en
discute annonce le ministre qui se dit
prêt à faire la vérité sur ce qui est
arrivé à yvan colonna victimes vous
l'avez dit d'une violente agression
alors qu'il purgeait une peine de prison
à perpétuité pour sa participation à
l'assassinât du préfet erignac en 1998
présentée comme une opération de la
dernière chance la visite du ministre de
l'intérieur laisse toutefois assez
sceptique le huffington post qui juge
que les choses n'ont guère avancé depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron les
revendications des nationalistes étant
tout à peu près les mêmes depuis cinq
ans qu'il s'agisse de l'obtention d'un
statut d'autonomie de plein droit pour
la corse ou de la co officialité de la
langue corse d'après andré phase iib
politologue à l'université de corte
l'agression divan colonna aurait été une
étincelle sur un baril de kérosène
rempli depuis cinq ans les violentes
manifestations en corse observé de près
aussi par la presse internationale
courrier international a recensé
quelques unes de ses analyses de la
presse étrangère au royaume uni le daily
express estiment que le ko je cite s'est
installé en france tandis que le journal
catalan la vanguardia évoque lui un
malaise corse qui ne se seraient jamais
résorber qui demeurait un problème grave
pour la france où le gouvernement fait
face à une situation périlleuse c'est
toujours à moins d'un mois de la
présidentielle un gouvernement aux abois
d'après le journal belge le soir qui
s'inquiète d'un risque de violence de
haute intensité si yvan colonna venait à
mourir
enfin le site observe algérie relève que
les candidats à la présidentielle dans
leur grande majorité reste muet sur
cette question corse évacués du débat
les candidats se concentrant sur la
question de l'immigration du prix des
carburants ou encore bien sûr la guerre
en ukraine la guerre en ukraine hélène
qui est toujours à la une de la presse
internationale
bien sûr on revient qui revient pendant
sur la visite hier des chefs de
gouvernement polonais tchèques et
slovènes à kiev déplacement pour
exprimer le soutien de l'union
européenne au peuple ukrainien on a les
quotidiens polonais et tchèques qui
expriment leur fierté de cette
initiative à l'image du tabloïd polonais
fakt qui évoque un voyage courageux en
ukraine un périple qui a débuté hier à
l'aube lorsque les trois chefs de
gouvernement ont pris le train pour kiev
et qui n'a été révélée que lorsqu'ils
ont franchi la frontière entre la
pologne et l'ukraine neige souligne
qu'il s'agit là du premier voyage à kiev
de dirigeants étrangers depuis le début
de l'invasion russe une visite c'est lui
et on l'a vu par le premier ministre
ukrainien volodimir zelensky qui a
évoqué un signe de soutien fort dans une
période difficile
d'après le quotidien tchèque les trois
premiers ministres ont appelé quant à
eux à l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne
au-delà du symbole la réalité de la
guerre ce sont ces trois millions de
réfugiés ukrainiens qui ont déjà quitté
pour le journal suisse le temps cette
crise doit être aussi interrogé en
profondeur les pays occidentaux sur
l'accueil des autres réfugiés qui fuient
des guerres plus éloignées qui eux aussi
méritent une véritable protection d'où
ce dessin de chappatte en cours 3 la une
et qui montre des réfugiés des européens
accueillant à bras ouverts les réfugiés
ukrainien mais qui sont beaucoup plus
réticents en revanche envers tous les
autres venus d'afrique du proche orient
la guerre et ses ravages partout dans le
monde en syrie des milliers de personnes
se sont rassemblées en d'en parler dans
le journal hier et idleb pour commémorer
enfin notamment headley pour commémorer
le onzième anniversaire du début du
conflit qui a ravagé leur d'après le
guardian certains de ces manifestants
ont dit espérer que l'invasion de
l'ukraine qui est soutenu ouvertement
par leur président bachar al assad
suscite un nouvel intérêt pour leur
propre co ce qui se passe en ukraine
aujourd'hui est similaire à la situation
ici l'ennemi est le même et le but est
le même a notamment déclaré l'un d'entre
eux la guerre en ukraine pauline qui
risque d'aggraver la famine dont
souffrent les victimes d'une autre
guerre tout à fait oublier celle là la
famine des yéménites sur les sur le sort
desquels il fatto quotidiano tente
d'alerter ce matin l'opinion occidentale
dans ce pays qui a toujours été parmi
les plus pauvres du monde et qui est
aujourd'hui parmi les plus dévastées de
la planète la mort prend non seulement
la forme des armes mais aussi de la
famine et de la maladie rappelle le
quotidien qui rappelle au cirque la
guerre au yémen a fait plus de 370 morts
en sept ans on ne vous quitte pas là
dessus avons nous dira tout à l'heure
pauline je vous propose de jeter ainsi à
l'observateur paalga le journal
burkinabè salue le travail de son
compatriote l'architecte francis kéré
premier africain à être récompensée par
le prix pritzker qui en quelque sorte le
prix nobel de l'architecturé
une récompense attribuée pour son
engagement en faveur de la justice
sociale et que cet architecte a
accueilli par ces mots tout le monde
mais avec la qualité tout le monde
mérite le luxe et tout le monde mais
avec le confort nous sommes liés les uns
aux autres et les préoccupations en
matière de climat de démocratie et de
pénurie il concerne tous merci beaucoup
et l'aisne à tout à l'heure